this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy if you're not sure if your
meals or where they should be it covers
your bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard pressed to
find a more nutrient dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient-dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you are getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and i'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for sleep enhancing sleep and
asleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so i used it and here we
are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping as cool as
55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit it also splits your
bed in half so your partner can choose a
totally different temperature my
girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she loves the heat
and we can have our own bespoke
temperatures on either side which is
exactly what we're doing now for me and
for many people the result eight sleep
users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40 and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for enhanced recovery so
you can take on the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250 off of
the pod pro cover that's a lot simply go
to eight sleep dot com slash tim or use
code tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t sleep.com
tim or use coupon code tim tim
eightsleep.com
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss and welcome to
a very special episode of the tim
ferriss show recorded at many degrees
below
zero and my guest today
i met on the road i did not expect to
meet her and i met her in antarctica
sue flood
sue flood is amazing sue is a
photographer and former bbc filmmaker
her work has taken her and still takes
her all over the world but she has a
special passion for the wildlife and icy
beauty of antarctica which is where we
met as i mentioned a durham university
zoology graduate sue spent 11 years with
the bbc natural history unit working on
series including the blue planet and
planet earth with sir david attenborough
we talked quite a bit about him before
turning her focus to photography her
most recent book emperor the perfect
penguin is absolutely spectacular it's
stunning with a forward by sir michael
palin was published in september 2018.
check it out at the very least look it
up online to see some of the imagery she
has appeared on screen for the bbc
discovery channel and national
geographic been featured on the series
cameramen who dare and has had her
images in national geographic bbc
wildlife geo and other distinguished
publications her work has won many
awards and competitions including travel
photographer of the year international
photographer of the year international
garden photographer of the year and a
royal photographic society silver medal
in recognition of her photographic
achievements sue was invited to meet her
majesty the queen during a special
adventures and explorers event held at
buckingham palace she has so many
adventures to share so many incredible
stories and it was just an honor
and a thrill
also a gas we laughed a lot to meet sue
unexpectedly in antarctica and i knew
that we had to sit down and record this
episode you can find her online sioux
flood
s-u-e-flood.com instagram sioux flood
photography twitter sioux flood photos
facebook sue flood photos we'll link to
all of those in the show notes at tim
dot blog podcast and now without further
ado please enjoy a very wide-ranging and
what was for me a very enjoyable
conversation a hilarious conversation
with sue flood
thank you for being here i am delighted
to be here in my cozy
podcasting studio
and
how would you describe where we're
sitting right now why don't we start
with that yeah it this is definitely not
quite as cozy as i'd imagined so we are
sitting
in the weddell sea at the most remote
camp in the antarctic right now
and we are sitting in a tent with a
table made of snow and ice
and looking out the window we can see a
twin otter
and some emperor penguins
so it's cool in every sense of the word
it is cool on on every level and as i
was mentioning before
we clicked or i clicked recorded using
the royal wii already
that i've tested this gear in some very
hot conditions but never in very very
cold so i'm watching battery very
closely why don't we start since you
mentioned penguin
we're here
or the guests are here certainly to see
penguins
you are a penguin master of sorts
we'll get into that
where does this word penguin come from
oh that's very cool so i'm welsh i
hailed from north wales born in a place
called cintassiff and living in a place
called slantedvale
near the edge of snowdonia rolls off the
tunnel it certainly does roll off the
tongue
and
there's a community
of people from wales who settled in
patagonia in south america
and pen is the word for head and gwyn is
the word
white so penguin whitehead
and it's thought that the first welsh
sailors who came over to south america
they saw magellanic penguins as they're
now known
and
called these birds penguin white-headed
you know birds but there is still a
community of people who speak welsh in
patagonia so there is a connection
between whales and penguins it's so wild
yeah i've already mentioned that as i
was on my
i'm not going to say first i'm not going
to say seventh glass of wine probably
second and a half glass of wine i was
like you got to be kidding me and you
can hear snow machines in the background
that's part of this audio verite you
mentioned
absolutely the aircraft and this is a
what would you call this a working camp
it's not exactly is it a station is this
considered a station not a station but
yeah a working camp that is put up
especially for the purpose and that snow
machine you hear is cutting away some of
the let's say waste that will be flown
out back to south america because we
have to keep this place absolutely
pristine so everything can i mean
everything
bodily products get flown back out to
south america to keep this place as
beautiful as it could possibly be it's
like a
burning man with fewer bikinis
this is true and
i wanted to
have this conversation
on tape because
i recalled and i have this experience
every once in a while
when you and i were
trekking back from the
empire penguin colony
dragging our sleds behind us which are
attached to us at the waist
and you're telling me all these stories
and i thought god damn it i really wish
this were being recorded
god it bothered me so much
but we've spent a little bit of time
together certainly in close quarters
yeah because we have the
mountain tents in which we sleep and
then we have one structure right next to
us what is this even considered it's
almost if people can imagine
this is not the best description but a
wine barrel laying on its side cut it in
half horizontally and then you have the
top half you put it on top of snow looks
something like that but what is this
considered so this is a structure called
a weather haven and it is absolutely
fantastic very strong once you've put it
up and metal hoops covered in a strong
canvassy material and that's our dining
tent and it gets very very toasty in
there um but then if you've got a nice
warm sleeping bag it can be really
toasty in your tent maybe minus 20 or so
the worst but then you get into your
nice warm sleeping bag and stick on your
headphones and
the only thing to disturb the silence is
probably my snoring heard throughout the
camp and hopefully you have eye shades
as well because it is
incredibly bright here yeah at the
moment
24 hours a day which has been
difficult to get accustomed to i'm not
sure if you ever do but
the light prompt every time it would
peep through my
the cracks in my eye shades i would pop
up thinking oh it is morning and check
the alarm be like no it's one in the
morning it is technically the morning
but it's one or two in the morning
let's uh pull a hard left you mentioned
this yesterday and i thought it might be
an interesting place to to to start the
chronology
so
this is gonna sound strange to people
listening but tell us about the very
early days of your time on this planet
and hips
what happened to you whoa
i was
due to be born on thursday the 12th of
august and i was actually a day late
born on friday the 13th
and my poor parents were told
that i would never walk um
and i had a
my hips weren't formed properly and they
were told i'd always be in a wheelchair
so you know they were obviously
devastated by that and as a consequence
my poor dad had a lifelong aversion to
friday the 13th but they tried this
revolutionary new treatment at the time
to
try and
build this special frame to hold my legs
in a certain position and i was able to
kind of recover and so a couple of years
later i was toddling around and the fine
physical specimen you see before you
today is so but you know it's i often
think about how lucky i've been to
to not turn out the way they thought i
would turn out and not long ago
as i understand it correct my memory
here you came across that brace which i
guess is almost like a almost like a
retainer for
your entire body right
were they like stiff suspenders that
would hold your hips in a particular
position
it's a little um
x-shaped cross with hooks on the end of
it and it would hook over my shoulders
and then hook under my backside to sort
of hold my legs in a certain position
and
my mum used to tell me it was just awful
because they'd put me into this thing
and i would just cry and cry and cry but
they were told that they had to do this
to try and you know give me a chance to
to possibly walk so and yeah we
unfortunately my father passed away
recently and we were clearing out the
house and
found this little thing and my brother
was saying oh check that out and i said
no i'm gonna gonna keep it and that's
in my office just as a constant reminder
that i've been very lucky
how much of it is a reminder of being
lucky
versus something else or maybe it's a
combination say of overcoming adversity
i don't it's a leading question of
course and i'm asking but i'm wondering
if you could just expand a bit on why
you would want to have that at the ready
as a reminder
never to take anything for granted is
you know i feel like i've
lived a
super privileged life not in any
financial sense but in a
my mum used to say i've lived the life
of five people and
i have my absolute dream job it's what
i've wanted to do since i was a kid and
i
as a child i would watch david
attenborough on all these wildlife
documentaries and there were two people
who really really inspired me one was
david attenborough i remember seeing him
crawling around in the rwandan jungle
with mountain gorillas and thinking wow
that's a cool job and then also my dad
my dad used to be in the merchant navy
so he would have all these amazing
stories from japan and china and burma
as it was and
and we had this big camp forward chest
he brought back from being at sea with
kimonos and hats and
headhunter swords from borneo and
all this incredibly cool stuff and it
was inspirational as a child and
but yeah i never dreamt i'd actually get
to to do this dream job of being a
wildlife filmmaker but i did
and it wasn't quite as as simple as just
signing up wasn't it as i understand it
there wasn't a sign-up sheet so
so if we go back to then
the the inspiration so you have these
figures your father david attenborough
probably among others but those two
primary inspiring you yeah when did you
start and how did you start finding your
way towards
this job that you have now what did the
early chapter or earliest chapters look
like i had no idea how to go about it i
i wrote to the bbc
to the natural history unit as it's
called which is a special department in
bristol that makes all of the bbc's
wildlife documentaries and a very kindly
producer there saw my letter
and bothered to reply and of course they
get
thousands of letters from people wanting
to make wildlife forms with david
attenborough of course
but i went and studied zoology at
university so i went to durham
university in the uk
and
this producer had said look you need to
put something on your resume that will
make us
take a second look because we get lots
of people with their zoology degrees or
their biology degrees or whatever
so i went managed to get onto this
really cool expedition to australia
and i had to raise money to go on that
and i was working for the queensland
national parks and wildlife service and
for three months unpaid diving on the
barrier reef doing these
surveys for crown of thorns starfish
which were damaging the reef white water
rafting through the rain forest and
building this path through the
rainforest
and caving in the outback in chilego so
this was all
cave diving no caving going into caves
into these like this limestone cave
system that was a
character building experience since i
don't like the dark and i don't like it
close spaces so that was a great mix and
then i also i'd heard about a place
called bermuda biological station and
they had this three-month work study
program where you could volunteer and
assist the marine biologists so i
managed to get onto that and the three
months became eight months
and it was really great experience being
out there because i was able to use that
time it was an unpaid position again so
i didn't have the money to do this but i
was racking up really useful experience
i got my food and my board and built up
a credit card bill and i was assisting
the marine biologists as i say and then
there was this team
who came out from the uk and they had
been working excavating the
mary rose and the mary rose was this
was henry viii's flagship so this
incredible
vessel that had been found and
they had managed to
excavate this ship and they were now
coming out these specialists to dive on
a wreck called the sea venture which had
sunk in 1609
um and
so i volunteered in the days of snail
mail to could i possibly help them and
they took me on to go and help that team
as well as working at the bio station
could i bookmark this for one second so
don't lose your place okay i want to
rewind to this letter that you sent so
they get thousands of letters
do you recall at all what you said in
this letter i'm just wondering why
because it's not physically possible
that the producer who received it
replied to
the many thousands of letters that were
received what did you put in that letter
do you have any idea yeah i well and i
have his reply somewhere at home so it
was along the lines of
ever since i was a child i've watched
david attenborough's documentaries he's
inspired me
to want to become a wildlife filmmaker
i'm going off to university to study
zoology i'd love to come and work for
the bbc and
can you give me any advice that kind of
thing and this person mike salisbury he
was
he's a really kind generous guy and he
it's typical of him to bother replying
and he was the producer on a lot of the
big attenborough series so things like
life of birds
life in cold blood all these um actually
and that was with my friend miles but
he'd worked on all these big
key series and some of the older ones
like living planet and so on that was
the question to him
so he receives the letter replies the
letter
i want to connect a couple of dots
to you arriving in australia yeah so
this was let me get this operation rally
yeah so this was straight after
university i'm sorry what was the
producer's name again uh mike salzberg
mike so mike
in effect please
please feel free to fact check this but
said we get a lot of people who check
these
several boxes you'd best differentiate
yourself right and add something
absolutely add some special sauce yeah
how do you go from that to arriving in
australia so this
operation rally had been started up by
prince charles and also a guy called
john blachford snell and the idea of it
was to give young people a chance to do
community work conservation work you
know character building stuff and i come
from this very tiny village in north
wales where not much happens and um a
friend at university said hey look at
this because it was all over the tv in
the papers it was advertised it was
advertised yeah absolutely it was very
very popular
and you know wow this seems amazing and
she said let's apply
and in the confident way i have i said
you're never going to get onto that
she's come on come on let's apply and
anyway we applied so you had to fill out
this form this very detailed form
if you got through that you got
interviewed and i remember going into
this
dusty old room university being
interviewed by some equally dusty old
men and thinking and they were all
terribly
terry posh i guess and thinking there's
no way i'm gonna get through this but i
did get through the interview and then
you got onto what was called a selection
weekend where you went away
for a whole weekend and they put you
through your paces
yeah and you know i remember going to
sleep in this tent at about 10 o'clock
at night and then they wake you up at
one in the morning and we got given a
box with a dead rabbit and some potatoes
and things to make your evening meal and
you know no one wanted to touch the
rabbit but you know i did zoology so i
was happy with that and and then the
fiesta resistance at the end of the
weekend in
a very cold november in newcastle was to
there was an outdoor swimming pool
unheated
where they told us to jump in and swim a
couple of lengths and at that point my
friend alice who encouraged us to apply
she'd also got through she probably
burst out crying and
she did not get on and um
i think i was made to stir the stuff
maybe i'm just more used to the cold wow
so alice i hope i hope alice gets some
chocolates or christmas cards
for that push for that nudge in that
direction okay thank you very much that
was great i'm very glad we filled in
some gaps there so then
bada bing bada boom you're in australia
yeah you end up in bermuda yeah this
crew from the uk shows up
they
i suppose among other things are doing
wreck dives yeah and
they bring up what was the date you said
on
1609. and they were we were finding all
these really cool things like um
shoes like these leather shoes that
being preserved from being buried in
this and you volunteered to do this i
did volunteer and coin weights and
because i was because i heard that they
were coming out i thought wow does not
sound amazing and by now when i was at
university i
knew that there was a chance of getting
onto this operation rally i'll be at a
very small chance i thought and also so
i learned to dive when i was at
university in the hope that i
got accepted
and could go and do this dive project on
the barrier reef but you know geez i
never thought i'd get to do anything
like that
it was amazing and i i never thought i'd
get to australia it may as well have
been on the moon as far as i was
concerned because i had been to
france
and that was it
so i i was 20 years old and i hardly
traveled wow all right so try to think
here because you have as as we were i
guess we were chatting yesterday and
our now mutual friend um was asking you
key life lessons takeaways you mentioned
carpe diem yeah because you seem very
good at taking advantage of these
sliding door moments where you sort of
feel like opportunity sliding however
you also have
this
long-term
chance favors the prepared mind
type of orientation because you did
the diving in the hopes that one day if
you were accepted yeah you would make
the cut which you ended up yeah being
able to do
how do we go from
that point in time
the diving that you're doing
to
not to provide a spoiler but to david
attenborough
well there's no rush so whatever
whatever the path
is direct or meandering as it may be i'm
just curious how how we go from there
well it was quite an interesting
trajectory so
by now i got some interesting things on
my resume you know i've got the
experience of bermuda i got the
experience in
the australian in queensland with the
national parks
and so now i was writing to the bbc
and saying well actually now i've done
this so instead of getting rejection
letters if i applied for a job now i was
getting interviews so you know first of
all it was i'm getting through to the
last couple of hundred
for the job then it's the last 50 then
i'm down to the last 10
and i pause for one second up to that
point how many letters
of or communication of one sort or
another had you sent to the bbc i would
write pretty regularly and there was a
what happened there was you know i get
encouragement from people also there
were a couple of wildlife film festivals
i would go to and i'd just go hi here i
am and still here i'd love to be a
researcher but you know not quite
getting there and then um
i got to the last two
for a job and i didn't get it oh and it
was for this children's tv program
called the really wild show
but the producer guy called paul appleby
he was really kind and he said look you
didn't quite get the job but would you
like to come and spend the day in the
studio and one of the people who had
interviewed me for the job it's very
kind yeah it was very kind he's a nice
guy and
one of the people it was a board of
three people interviewing me and
one of them said if you're ever in
bristol
just let us know come for coffee in the
bbc canteen and come and tell us what
you've been up to so of course i
pretended i was in bristol i haven't
happened to be a
direct path to bristol exactly
so i you know took a five-hour coach
ride to get there and this producer
michael bright we had a coffee and he
you know what have you been up to what
have you been doing and he said i don't
suppose you've got any free time have
you because there was this researcher
meant to be starting today
and she just didn't turn up and he said
you know have you got any free time and
i said absolutely and he said when could
you start and i said today yesterday
yeah so i
was given a three-day contract
[Laughter]
and yeah and then that got extended by
another three days then a few weeks and
then what was the project there was a
series called wildlife on one
um actually just before that there was a
oh that's right wildlife on one as in
bbc one bbc one no no back in that
time just for context for people who are
not from
from the motherland not from britain uh
in the case of us yanks at least
at that time as i recall my childhood
for instance was it effectively what bbc
one two three four
and then it was bbc one and two one and
two yeah and then there was itv
and channel four channel four yeah there
we go
but the in the sense that you're getting
incredible
coverage to be on bbc one yeah
absolutely a larger percentage of the
population than people now can
younger generations would imagine
because
it's not like there were a thousand
channels to choose from no exactly so
and this was the bbc's longest running
nature program at the time so it's
presented by david attenborough and
wow so i was getting to work with david
uh getting closer closer
yeah absolutely so what did working with
him look like was it through multiple
layers did you have direct communication
what was that like
that's a great question too because i
remember
phoning him up and i imagined that there
was going to be some secretary answered
the phone
and uh you know you hear his voice
because hello
and uh i said oh david hello it's sue
flood
and i'm surprised that you answer the
phone he said well yes i do live here
no
so you know i had a producer as my boss
and so on and i was the researcher but
occasionally i'd have to speak to him
and that's still exciting because he's
such a wonderful guy but yeah it was
that was my first break was working on
on wildlife on one and then there was a
series that was coming up
with the provisional
name oceans
and this was going to be a series an
eight-part series that was going to be a
big budget series on the natural history
of the oceans
and this is the series that became the
blue planet
and one of the cameramen had told me
about this and he said you know you
should try and get a job on that because
it's going to be a really
really good series and i said they won't
get me for something like that but he
said well you're a dive instructor i was
a dive instructor by now and i'd worked
for a smaller tv company on a series
about the oceans as well so i knew my
way around and
yeah so i applied and then
my boss alistair father gill alistair
was the head of the natural history
great name yeah very english and um
alistair said you've got the job and
i
recall exactly what i said i said that's
better than winning the lottery
and it was it was better than winning
the lottery even now if you could turn
back the clock and i had the choice
between winning the lottery and working
on blue planet i would choose working on
blue planet
for people who don't know or maybe just
have a passing familiarity since the
name has come up quite a few times with
david attenborough yeah
who is david attenborough just so we
that we can paint that picture just a
little bit before we keep going what has
made him so
iconic oh well he has a longevity in
terms of
wildlife presenters but i mean he's so
much more than that he's now 95.
he has inspired millions and millions
and millions of people around the world
he's just recently spoken at cop and as
a child you know he was presenting these
amazing documentaries as he still does
but he's just an incredible communicator
and just has this
constant
fascination for everything and he's
not just an expert biologist he's an
expert on
all sorts of things paleontology
type of china
amber oh all sorts of things and he is a
fascinating and lovely man who um as i
say he's inspired millions of people he
also used to head up bbc two but he was
going off doing things in his 20s that
were
really extraordinary going off exploring
in places like new guinea and
remote parts of indonesia and
doing some very very cool things i
recall seeing as a child now for people
listening i'll play foil just as a
stand-in for some people to say tv
presenter that's like a tv host on our
side of the pond
how hard could that be isn't he just
reading a script isn't that what happens
oh
so not like that i mean he he had many
of the ideas for series so he would come
up with the idea and he would be writing
the scripts and the thing with david is
he makes his job look like falling off a
log but it really isn't it's incredibly
difficult to get to that point oh yeah
and um you know he just
to go into a recording studio and he's
there reading the script you've
hopefully written for him and he's
always going to come up with some
improvements and but yeah it's really so
much more because he's out in the field
and he's just as i say got this
incredible enthusiasm
for the subject matter and an incredible
knowledge and
it is absolutely infectious and
anybody in the bbc natural history unit
would have been inspired by him as a kid
and
he can do no wrong
and the voice i mean let's not forget
about the voice and here we are at union
glacier or
or pause pause snow lip
not snow leopard i'm mixing up my
leopards leopard seal the footage
but just the just the pacing the pacing
yeah is he's
so outstanding he's absolutely he is
so unbelievably kind and nice and um
there's this great story where because
his number used to be in the phone book
and
i always remember him saying how this
little boy had phoned him up
because his pet rabbit was ill
here he is phoning up
david so david now um
because he was knighted of course but
it's like calling the president of the
united states to be like yeah the the
the the traffic light at my corner
he's not really doing what he's supposed
to do exactly and one of the um
i'm jumping ahead a little here but we
can jump all over the place
one of my top few experiences in my life
a couple of years ago i'd done this book
and one of the paragraphs in the
acknowledgments was thanking david for
all he'd done to inspire me as a kid and
and i'd gone to this book launch for
a friend's book um
michael palin and he had written this
book called erebus and i had a copy of
my book in my bag
and david was there so the three of us
had a drink together and i said david
please forgive me for doing this but i'm
never going to be able to do it again
and i basically took my book out and
held onto his arm and read out this
paragraph and the acknowledgements about
what he meant to me and how it inspired
me and then i got to the end of this
paragraph and
slightly teary-eyed and then he gave me
this big hug and uh yeah it was great so
amazing full circle and that book just
for people listening i'm sure i will
have already mentioned it in the intro
but which book is this it's a book
called emperor the perfect penguin and
i've been lucky to spend a lot of time
with emperor penguins which as you know
now tim are the biggest of all the 18's
penguin species they're the you know the
happy feet penguin if you like and they
are so spectacularly beautiful and i'd
done a book mainly photo led book about
emperors
and why to me they were the perfect
penguin and i've been photographing them
over about
14 years crikey that's a long time and
so that was a book came out a couple
years ago and
literally as we're sitting here like we
can look and we're looking at look at
that in between in between some
structures here
and we see a line yeah it looks almost
like cutter ants on their way back to
the colony but in this case
it is a line of
pretty closely spaced emperor penguins
yeah
could you explain what tobogganing
well they they can walk you know maybe
even 100 kilometers from the edge of the
ice where they've been feeding back to
the colony to feed their chicks and
of course toddling the lung on their
little legs takes them a long time but
they'll flop onto their bellies and then
propel themselves along using their
flippers and their very strong feet
that's exactly what they're doing now so
we're just sitting here watching this
trail of the most beautiful bird in the
world
tobogganing along on their bellies going
off to feed their chicks it's very cool
they're a lot faster on their bellies
than i would have expected they really
move they really really move they're
like oblong bowling balls i mean they
really they really hustle and
you have this beautiful photograph that
you showed the group here which is of
the
the track
left behind
which would be just completely
befuddling
to decipher unless you knew what was
going on because how are they propelling
themselves they do glide but they do
glide but they use their feet they've
got really strong feet that have special
lipids to help stop them freezing
because of course they're standing
around
in the middle of winter maybe minus 50
or so with windchill and the males will
be incubating the egg so
they'll be using those strong feet to
propel themselves long and then using
their flippers to push in the snow so
you get this very cool track of where
their bellies rubbing through the snow
and then these little
sharp lines either side of that but yeah
you can never get bored of emperor
penguins and you know a big one that as
i say the biggest of the of the penguins
but the
at all one a big one would be about one
point two five meters tall which is you
know pretty big yeah it is big yeah
weighs 44 ish feet tall yeah something
like that you said 40 kilos yeah above
yeah thereabouts and
you mentioned the males incubating so
the the eggs are laid then the males
will
stand guard and keep the egg heated by
putting it into what is this they have
they have a thing called a brood pouch
which is a bare bit of skin at the
bottom of their belly and they'll tuck
the egg in there so the female of course
lays the egg she will pass it over to
the male
and she'll then be zipping off to sea
and leaving him to do all the work of
looking after this egg during the winter
but it's you know it's a really
precarious thing to pass this egg in
super cold temperatures over to the mail
and then this big sort of flap of
insulating skin goes over the top of the
egg and he's able to maintain that egg
at about 34 35 degrees
even though the outside temperature can
be minus 50 centigrade and for
just to emphasize the endurance required
after that point after the pass has been
successful yeah
the males will stand around for what
anywhere between two two and a half
months and lose something like 30 40 40
of their body yeah it's not incredible
so they cannot eat for about four months
um from the time they're arriving back
at the edge of the ice they're finding
their partner
mating
taking care of the egg sitting on the
egg for two two and a half months so
that can be about four month period that
they're not eating and then when the
chick hatches
the first meal they get is from the
father and that he
produces this kind of mix of protein and
fat that he feeds to the chick from this
special gland in his esophagus so
just an amazing life cycle that they can
breed over the antarctic winter like
they're incredibly harsh so incredible
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
you can ucan what you eat and how you
live exercise sleep stress all play an
important role in how your body handles
glucose it's main form of energy you
might think of blood sugar that is
glucose when glucose levels are steady
and you avoid spikes you're improving
your metabolic fitness an important way
to take control of your metabolic
fitness is to eat and fuel with foods
that help regulate blood sugar to help
enhance my own metabolic health i was
introduced to you can by dr peter etia
who said there is no carb in the world
like it ucan's patented ingredient super
starch has the remarkable ability to
provide a steady release of energy
without spiking blood sugar levels i use
ucan's energy powders and low calorie
bars to maintain focus throughout long
days for exercise better performance
when training and to avoid fatigue
without making metabolic compromises
when i need a scooby snack when i need a
little pick-me-up i reach for you can
ucan has a variety of different products
with super starch to help you balance
your blood sugar from energy powders and
bars to granola and almond butter
there's a whole suite check out my
favorites at
ucan.co tim that's ucan dot co slash tim
and save 30 on your first order that's
ucan dot co slash tim
so let's let's flash back to blue planet
now you've captured why don't you just
give people a teaser of
some of the firsts that you've captured
so we're going to bounce around a little
bit but then we're going to go back to
blue planets so what are some of the
firsts that you've captured yeah i've
been so lucky to photograph some very
cool things so um the first shoot i went
on for blue planet with cameraman de
gallon and tom fitz we went to monterey
bay in california and that was to film
killer whales or orca hunting gray
whales as they migrated up the west
coast of the states towards the suburb
feeding grounds in alaska
then a couple of months later
doug and i went up to
lancaster sound jones sound big pardon
in the canadian high arctic where there
was a super rare event of
polar bears hunting beluga whales that
were caught in something called the
sarsat which is a hole in the ice being
kept open by the movement of animals and
the reason they're trapped it's not
because it's a pond it's because they're
they're mammals
and ultimately if the next opening in
the ice is too far away they have to
stay yeah so being marine mammals
belugas have to come to the surface to
breathe
and it's thought that what had happened
they'd been feeding at the ice edge
waiting for the ice to break up before
they could move into the summer feeding
grounds and they've been a bit of a cold
snap and in still conditions the ice can
freeze very suddenly overnight the sea
ice and so that ice had encroached on
them and trapped them in this hole but
we were camping on the sea ice when we
were filming this a bit like camping on
the sea ice here but with the difference
that you don't hear it kind of groaning
and under your tent
in such a large area as we're in here
you've certainly had no shortage of
adventure and i want to
explore a bit more the
experience in monterey bay
because this phenomenon of orcas hunting
uh which type of whale was it again uh
gray whales gray whales yeah and i guess
specifically what are they referred to
as the sort of adolescent or young
you've got mothers
with their calves
so the calves are born in san ignacio
lagoon in baja california and they're
going to mine great up the west coast of
the states to the summer feeding grounds
in alaska
and
nancy black who was the biologist we
worked with she had this theory that it
was the immature mothers that were
taking a shortcut across monterey bay
canyon this very deep water
and we knew that national geographic had
tried to film this and not been
successful and then my boss alistair who
i mentioned before he gave me the task
of deciding should we go and film this
so that was obviously quite onerous
deciding you know shall we spend this
money to go and give it a go
and
we were extremely lucky that on day
three someone reported this behavior and
nancy who runs a whale watch business
and she's a biologist in in california
she had never seen an attack from start
to finish
in the whole time she'd been watching
this so she said this is my hunch i know
roughly when it happens
because you know the blue planet team
had gone off to the this marine mammal
conference and had said if anyone's got
any stories that they think would be
interesting for us let us know so this
this uh really interesting situation and
day three we saw
these killer whales hunting grey whales
it was for just one second sure so so
day three i don't want you to lose your
place you're mentioning that the the
younger mothers the so the theory goes
would take their calves straight across
the bay the short on the shortcut not
having the sort of
not having the life experience of the
more senior mothers who were [ __ ] the
[ __ ] the shores exactly we know take the
long dragons dragons be yeah
here we dragons exactly and
why had the
couple of questions you can answer them
in any order why do you think or perhaps
you know
the national geographic attempted failed
and then when you're tasked with
deciding go or no go
how did you think about
making that decision in other words
for instance maybe there's not much
downside to you personally in your
career for
if you say let's do it and it doesn't
work it's like well bad luck
maybe there are consequences but if it
actually pays off right then like the
upside is huge right so two things why
did whether it's speculation or or
something that you know why did natgeo
not capture the footage and then how did
you think about making the decision in
terms of them not making getting the
footage i think they were unlucky
because they had a fantastic cameraman
might degree who was he was a brilliant
cameraman and a wonderful person who's
sadly no longer with us but he and
another fantastic cameraman you know
they were really good guys and they
didn't manage to get it but then i
thought if they're sending them to do it
they obviously think it's
worth a try so
let's give it a go but then in terms of
trying to decide my whole life as a
wildlife filmmaker is trying to make
sure that the camera team was in the
right place at the right time
and i love logistics i love
the research
and some of these behaviors you know
if you're going to film something where
an animal is
it's well known what it does you know
maybe it's a lion going to hunt in pearl
or in zambia or something like that and
people are seeing that regularly but
when it's something that's not been
filmed before
you just trying to have to piece
together the bits of the jigsaw
so as i say this woman nancy black the
biologist she knew roughly where it was
happening
roughly when
and then you have to think about well
if you're not there you're not going to
get it so let's go and give it our best
shot work with her because she seemed to
be the person and she was indeed the
person who knew most about it
get a good boat
have a zodiac that we could get into to
go and film from and
all you can do is try and a zodiac is
what would you say i have 12 12 i don't
know how many meters long oh crikey
maybe about five meters yes roughly 15
feet long people have seen these before
they're they look i suppose they are
they inflated i mean yeah yeah inflated
around the the perimeter right they're
flat on the inside yeah with an outboard
motor yeah more navigable and we were
you know sitting and when we found this
event where the
killer whales were
surrounding this mum and calf and we
quickly clambered into the zodiac
i remember my mum saying when she saw a
photo of this you haven't got your life
jacket on because we got in so quickly
i'd forgotten to do that and at one
point the
gray whale mother was trying to shelter
under our boat
oh
so it was you know as a biologist it was
incredible to see this behavior you know
absolutely amazing behavior and
literally the killer whales were the
orca were close enough that if i'd
wanted to i could have touched them
because they were coming right round the
boat
but then
and as a filmmaker wow this is exciting
no one's fullness before you know how
incredible is that
very very
high octane stuff but then
you know as a human being it was
pretty grueling to sit and watch this
poor little calf get
drowned and then eventually
eaten but hey killer whales have to eat
killer whales for no reason exactly not
called cuddling whales
so
i'd love to get a bit more detail so how
large are
orcas compared to the cavs now let me
have a think about that i would say use
metric because
we have to accommodate the one of the
few holdouts in the world aka us i think
a big male orca would be about
30 feet 10 meters i need to check that
but i think that's what it would be as i
recall
but the calf
i guess the calf would have been about 5
meters 15 feet something like that okay
since i mean there's a size differential
but not as much as i would have expected
yeah and that's the big male or because
they can have a dorsal fin that's about
six feet high but the females would be
smaller why are their dorsal fins so
long so dorsal fin for people
imagine jaws the shark fan cutting
through the water on the let's just say
on the on the spine on the back that
that's the dorsal fin why is the dorsal
fin of the orca so long compared to the
length of its body
why is that i do not know the answer to
that why is it so big
i guess it's helping maybe it's acting a
bit like a a rudder or something and and
certainly i guess if you're traveling in
rough seas
other members of your pod can see you
because if you didn't have i'm just
hazarding a guest there because you know
they're an interesting society it's a
mature matriarchal society and
when the male calves grow up eventually
they'll be
they'll leave the pod and yeah and
you've got basically a group of females
and calves i mean they're extraordinary
animals and i've seen them do some
really neat behaviors
after blue planet i went on to produce a
film about killer whales we got to film
some really really cool behaviors
for example in the streets of gibraltar
between the southern tip of spain and
morocco
they were hunting bluefin tuna so
bluefin tuna will go into the
mediterranean to spawn and then about
august time they're coming back out of
the mediterranean and at that point
the fishermen along lining for them they
are so smart they had learned
that when the they'd been milling around
and you'd see them just swimming around
you know just keeping an eye on things
and then the minute a fishing boat
hooked
one they had clued in to
the sound of the winch as their winching
and as soon as they made a beeline for a
boat you knew that that boat hooked a
tuna and they would just be diving on
this line
and then the fishermen would haul it up
and it'd be big killer whale-sized bites
out of it and um
yeah i mean they're very impressive
animals it's like uh
some predators elsewhere will become
attuned if they're surrounded by hunting
to the sound of gunshot yes grizzlies
and so on question about orcas so in the
case of
monterey bay
are they is going to sound stupid
probably
are they hunting the gray whale calves
to primarily eat are they teaching
their young how to hunt
and
well let's start there is it is it
both yeah a bit of both and nancy had
this theory
that what they were doing
was eating the tongue
and leaving the rest of it and we were
able to film that and show it was that
was the case so what happens they've got
this thick layer of blubber but the
killer whales were going in sort of
through under the jaw into the soft
palate and
they drowned the calf by jumping
repeatedly on top of it and holding it
under and ramming into the side of it
and then they were actually eating the
tongue and once they'd done that they'd
leave it and then just swim away and dug
the camera and he got into the water and
was able to actually film this
slightly gruesome carcass of the whale
which then
sank to the bottom of the ocean and then
would be feeding other creatures so
again all part of nature's great cycle
i'll be a bit witness so if they're just
consuming the delicacy of the tongue
which is true for humans also if you
look at some history of say
some native american tribes would
regularly just remove the tongue of the
bison
and leave the rest of course which
should then get consumed by other things
yeah but
what is your theory
of what primarily was happening in that
case was it teaching hunting was it
sport was it simply sport
there was definitely an element of
teaching hunting and we we were able to
show that with the footage we got
because
there was a particular matriarch that
had a very noticeable little
notch in her fin so you could see that
she was leading the attacks if you like
but then she would hang back
and you could see
her and the other adult females hanging
back and letting the calves go in and
kind of have a go if you like so there
was definitely an element of teaching
and you know i've seen that with orca in
other places up in alaska for example
they were hunting meganzas so these sea
ducks would be swimming around on the
surface and then the whales would swim
underneath them
get hold of their feet and just pull
them under just pulling them under for a
few seconds and letting them go so these
birds were flustered and flopping around
and then they'd come up and do it again
just like playing and then of course
eventually they drown these poor ducks
but they are they're smart animals
they're smart animals coming back to the
the size of the dorsal fin i know that i
like that the signaling
theory is most in the hunting that
you've observed how much of it is
coordinated group hunting almost like a
wolf pack or something like that versus
solitary hunting far more so the the
former and there was a fantastic film
made by david and liz perak
some years ago gosh about
20 25 years ago called wolves of the sea
and they are just that walls of the seas
are coordinated hunting in a pack and
there are different types of killer
whales residents that hang around in one
place they tend to eat
fish there's transients that hang more
offshore and they tend to eat marine
mammals and then there's an offshore
type that's a bit of a mix of the two
but yeah i i
really enjoyed um working with my one
regret is i haven't got in the water
with them yet but one of these days is
it is it
what is the danger level in getting in
the water with workers there's never
been a case of a person being killed in
the wild by an orca i mentioned that
place near tarifa in spain where you
know they're coming out of the med after
spawning and one of the stories that i
just loved was um they'll have these
great big pens where they're catching
the fishermen are catching the tuna and
if they're not in great condition
they'll put them into the pens
to kind of fatten them up if you like
for later in the season
and this guy's his job was to repair
these nets make sure they're in good
condition no holes in them if you know
someone's caught it on their propeller
or something and he was there in the
water in his dive gear
sort of sewing up this net with a bit of
rope and he became aware that someone's
watching him and he turned and looked
over his shoulder and there's this
killer whale just sitting at his
shoulder watching him repair his neck
which yeah that would give you not
spooky at all not spooky at all that
would give you a wee bit of a fright but
god what a thrill
and and you'd mentioned also i'll give
you a visual cue and maybe you could
just
see if you remember i do remember
it takes it to a whole different level i
love this
so there's a cameraman called andrew
pennika in new zealand who worked on
this killer world film with me and he
was telling a story about his friend
diving in the poor knight islands in new
zealand which is this
absolutely brilliant dive spot and this
guy's swimming around
and then all of a sudden snags his leg
as he thought and he thought he'd caught
it on some you know fishing gear or
something like that and he turns round
and there's this orca this killer whale
that's basically holding his calf
between its jaws and just
gently squeezing his wetsuit with its
teeth sort of well this doesn't look
like it's going to taste too nice and
just let him go but yeah that would be a
i think you'd probably feel quite wide
awake after that
yeah
no extra coffee needed after that time
wow yeah incredible
what would you like to do if you got in
the water with workers
what would your dream scenario be i
would like to photograph them but then
equally it's you know nice to not have a
camera and just sit and observe them
because as i say they
no one has been killed by one and
we did have the intention when we were
filming the monterey bay sequence that
we'd get in the water but then we
decided not to do that because they were
really kind of thrashing around when
they were hunting the grey whales and i
think there's probably a very good
chance you might have got injured just
in the the melee this is as good a a
layup of a segway as i could hope for
they might as well use this opportunity
the divorce will
the divorce whale oh dear god well um so
doug who i mentioned earlier doug allen
doug is a fantastic fantastic
documentary cameraman but as i always
tell him not such a fantastic husband
but anyway and he proposed to me when we
were adrift on a piece of ice in the
canadian high arctic during the making
of the blue planet and with the classic
line if we get rescued will you marry me
um as i always tell him probably he
thought he was going to die to do that
but then some considerable time later
when we were working on planet earth
we were filming humpback whales in tonga
in the south pacific
which is
definitely my
favorite shoot from my time with the bbc
and we spent 10 weeks filming humpbacks
and the
humpback whales that were knee suddenly
latitudes when the winter approaches in
the antarctic they're going to move to
northerly climbs to have their calves so
places like tonga where you've got
shallow warm protected waters anyway we
were filming them and i was i we were
both in the water he's filming the mum
and calf and i'm filming him
filming the mum and car for the sequence
for discovery quite close and i was
quite close and i looked over the top of
the camera and realized i was way closer
to the cloth because i was on a very
wide angle lens and the calf was kind of
flopping around because it didn't have
the control that the mum had and you
know the mum's 45 feet long 15 meters
long and the calf was
about 15 feet 5 meters weighing about a
ton and this calf basically
bumped into me with its tail i mean
certainly not being aggressive or
anything just because it didn't have the
control the mother did i mean bump is uh
perhaps an understatement yeah
because i was filming at the time this
was all caught on camera and it just
really felt like
i'd been hit with a sledgehammer and i
thought straight away i've broken my leg
so i stuck my head above the water
and shouted to doug i've broken my leg
normally i would clip the video camera
on before i get in the water but this
day i hadn't because we got in the water
very quickly so i was just holding the
video camera and
that was slightly negatively buoyant so
it started sinking anyway given the
choice between rescuing me with the
potential broken leg or the camera
sadly there was no contest
so i was not in any doubt before the
incident that doug preferred his camera
to me but i was definitely left in no
doubt at all after that event so i
always joke and call out the divorce
whale but so we are divorced for every
number of reasons but that i think was a
a nail in the coffin but we do get on
much better now
i'll get my own back one of these days
you've had tremendous success in your
career
what
are some of the most common
mistakes
or any mistakes that you see
in novices
who are trying to
become or are but just in the early
stages of being wildlife photographers
we can start with that category
you need to walk a fine line between
being
determined
but not too pushy no one wants a pain in
the ass hopefully i'm not
but you need to
want to do that job more than anything
else in the world because
it is absolutely all-consuming and
i don't have kids and there are a very
small number of people who haven't made
a success of this career who do have
kids but it is a very small number but
yeah you just have to want to do it to
the exclusion of practically everything
else but
i did
i did want to do that and it's just been
a fabulous life getting to do
what i absolutely love
now you are
remarried yeah and
you
i was chatting with some other folks on
this trip also
just curious as to how the relationships
work like what the kind of agreements
are
since
some people here i don't know what your
split looks like but they'll spend
you know 200 plus days of the year
on the road and their significant other
is not on the road yes could you just
tell us a bit more about that
my husband chris he and i were
at primary school together so we met we
were 10 then didn't see each other for
37 years
a dear friend of mine judith owen
she's a fabulous singer-songwriter and
i've been to stay with her and her
husband harry shearer and santa monica
and photographed you this album
chris had seen a post i'd made about
this and and then he said you know wow
that's what an amazing voice this
woman's got and we had got back in touch
i invited him to go to the gig
and that's how we re-met after all this
time but he is not good in the cold
whereas doug was you know the world's
leading polar cameraman it's a bit of a
contrast there so i i think um he wishes
he'd married the tropical specialist but
he absolutely loves being at home he
loves being at home and we course we've
just had lockdown so we've been at home
together for almost a couple of years
and amazingly he seemed to have enjoyed
spending that time with me but yeah i
i'm gonna be away a lot probably the
next couple of years
trying to make up for a bit of lost time
and revenue but you know it's what i do
for a job and
i need to be able to go to these places
and do these things because it's what
makes me tick so it actually works out
really really well because it's
it's funny someone was joking about
having a you know a home husband and a
work husband because uh you know i like
working in the cold and have friends i
can do that with and and then chris
likes being back home in front of the
log fire in north wales
sounds like uh he and my girlfriend
would get along
when i first shared the description of
this trip and i sent it to her and if
she could sleep in a sauna
not to be confused with this what is it
um
we had some confusion earlier
i do not speak the queen's english
what's the song
what is that
sounds vaguely foreign the response that
she gave me when i shared it and i
sounded very enthusiastic because i was
i was downtown working very enthusiastic
emails like this is even more amazing
than i possibly could have imagined all
these caps
and then we talked about it later she
said yeah i really
hope you have the best time
because yeah you should go and
this is not for me she's probably on
holiday with chris as well they might be
they might be sitting in front of a log
fire i think there was some tropical
island somewhere
how many people
who are in relationships do you meet who
have
an opposite as you do in a sense
versus someone who
perhaps
understands
because they do the same type of work
because i've met some of both here yeah
is there a breakdown that you've seen or
just in your experience it's an
interesting one isn't it i think that
for me it definitely works better being
married to someone who's the opposite
than doing someone who's got similar
passions because
it's the sort of job where you have to
be very driven
you know you can't think oh i'm gonna
stay in the tent today when the polar
bears off doing something exciting
outside you know the longest we had in
one spell filming was 36 hours because
there was this interesting behavior
going on so you need to be 36 hours of
continuous filming yeah yeah
so um but that was super rare and that
was this polar bear's hunting beluga
whales thing so you have to be prepared
to to put up with discomfort but then
the really cool thing about my job now
is since i decided to leave the bbc
because you know i wanted to go out on a
high after planet earth
getting out at the top like rocky
marciano absolutely
just with smaller biceps
possibly yeah
and he um yeah no i did i want to i it
was just such an amazing experience and
by now i'd had 11 years you know working
on these david attenborough series and
this had been my absolute dream as a
child and
i just thought well
i've been doing photography as part of
my job so i've been promoted to
assistant producer associate producer
then producer and director and i thought
you know what i'm actually enjoying
photography
more than being a producer so i decided
to see if i could make a go of that now
quick interjection because i enjoyed
your presentation the other day time
really blurs here by the way like time
dilation and contraction it's very hard
to know like how tired you are or awake
you are i'm sure you figure it out over
time but for me i'm like
oh i'm so hungry and tired and it's
probably 11 in the morning oh wait it's
one it's one in the morning it's it's
very confusing to my circadian rhythm
but when i was
watching a presentation a couple days
ago it feels like a couple days ago
uh you mentioned that your photographs
were sort of inching their way
centimetering their way
closer to the covers with magazines yeah
right so that was that also part of the
reason you decided you know yes it was i
think i have i think i think there's a
shot i think there's a pretty good shot
here
yeah
i guess
well you know in the same way that as a
kid i thought if i don't give it a go to
try and work with david attenborough and
that was what going back to that
operation rally project in australia
what that gave me was the confidence to
at least try
and
if i didn't succeed at least i tried you
know better to have loved and lost and
not loved it all kind of thing and then
same with
this idea of the photography so i as you
mentioned i got
a shot of a great white shark on the
cover of
the bbc wildlife magazine and then i got
it on the cover of a national geographic
magazine
and then i had another shot on the back
cover of the national geographic
magazine and i thought well you know i'm
getting a bit closer here so let's give
it a go if it doesn't work out at least
i tried i won't be sitting here
wondering if i just succeeded so i i
handed him my notice and i had a really
good bit of luck the next day although
the old thing of you make your own luck
right so um i was asked the following
day did i want to join
this russian icebreaker that was going
to the north pole and they asked me did
i want to do that and um i was going to
go and speak about polar bears and other
arctic wildlife because i just finished
this film about polar bears so that led
to me
doing seven trips to the north pole by
nuclear icebreaker and getting to have
some wonderful experiences working on
this ship yeah quick quick question
what does nuclear ice breaker mean ice
breaker i understand what what is the so
rather than running on um
diesel or whatever it runs on nuclear
power and the russians have a number of
can you hear those emperor penguins in
the background isn't that great
[Laughter]
another reason that you don't sleep
normally this is right i mean the other
night about three in the morning there
was one clearly standing right outside
my tent and about two foot from my head
and then suddenly started calling which
was a rude awakening but lovely just to
build on that so people can fully
appreciate
these emperor penguins
do not have as i understand it any
terrestrial predators so when they are
out of the water
we briefly mentioned leopard seal we can
maybe come back to that but people can
certainly google it and see some crazy
imagery
on land they are utterly unafraid i mean
you can still freak them out if you move
too quickly or something but
i guess some of the staff here call them
the inspectors yeah because they'll come
right up to you and check you out it's
absolutely really incredible yeah and uh
you know there are very strict
guidelines about how close you can
approach them so you know no closer than
five meters etc but of course
if you sit still and wait
they'll come and check you out and it's
it's just a magical experience i mean
one time
i'd carried my camera bag out to the
colony and it was a really cold day it
was you know oh minus 22 centigrade and
i laid down i put my head on the camera
bag and was just listening to the chicks
and i actually fell asleep while i was
listening to them and my hand was
stretched out on the snow when i woke up
i know 15 20 minutes later and my arms
on the snow with my glove on and and
there was this little emperor penguin
chick with its little flipper stretched
out on my hand right next to me
but yeah going back to the icebreakers
the i mean i had seven trips on those
and um
lockdown has given me the chance to
think about
how i want to
slightly change how i'm working so
flying less you know cutting my carbon
footprint which has obviously been very
easy in the last year and a half because
i've hardly been anywhere but you know
flying less and
it was very cool in september a couple
of months ago i was asked to join
a hybrid electric ship going to the
north pole
this is this amazing ship which
new design and
owned by pono the french company so i'm
going to be working with them the next
couple years so it's really lovely to be
able to find this hybrid electric ship
running on liquefied natural gas and
battery power and just doing things in a
very different
luxurious way hurrah well you also
mentioned in a very quiet way right
which
which is i suppose obvious once you say
it but you're mentioning that you're on
deck
and being able to take these amazing
photographs of polar bears because the
ship is so quiet and you actually had to
ask some fellow passengers to pipe down
because their voice was the loudest yeah
it was larger than the ship it was
amazing
so we were able to stand there
photographing this mother and curb
you know playing around in the snow
clambering over the ice rolling just
behaving completely naturally not
affected by our presence it was yeah
absolutely wonderful so
being able to sort of tweak the way
you're doing your job is really
important one of the things that i've
seen you doing here with some mutual
friends is
going through
photographs discussing photography
what type of feedback do you give most
frequently when you are interacting with
people say at a camp like this
what are some of the things that people
perhaps don't pay enough attention to or
things that
are missed by folks who come here
because many people who come here are
experienced not necessarily
well trained but experienced
photographers yes i'm one of the few
people here who isn't carrying equipment
how do those feedback teaching sessions
go that's one of the things actually
that since i left the bbc that i've
really enjoyed doing is
teaching people and getting that
feedback from
people who watch these documentaries as
opposed to just being with people who
make them and i realized that actually
being with people and getting them to
observe the natural world and tell them
about animal behavior and help them
capture it with their cameras or their
iphones or whatever you know that's
something i really really enjoy doing so
and that's led to a number of
whether it's working for different
travel companies or private individuals
where i'm taking them on location and
doing that for them or maybe making a
book of their trip that sort of thing i
love doing that and just trying to point
out different bits of behavior so
because as a zoologist you know that's
been very helpful getting to be a
wildlife filmmaker or photographer so
you can
you know observe the animals and point
those things out to them and try and get
them to look for the
little moments
that make a special photograph not just
it's standing there but you know what is
the about the scene in front of you that
you can capture and turn into
a special moment what might be an
example something like emperors you know
when when you're watching them so
because i've been fortunate to to
photograph them so much you can tell
when an adult has paired up with its own
chick you know it's coming back from
feeding at the colony it's warped now at
the moment we're about 10 miles from the
edge of the ice so it's walked about 10
miles to come and bring food to the
chick
and they locate their chick amongst
thousands of birds by calling to it and
they will find their chick
no name sort of thing
i'm so much more poetic than that it is
and they have i guess someone was saying
they're bi-harmonic so it's it has a
very particular sound it's fantastic
sound and then the chicks are calling to
the adults and oh it's just lovely but
you know you can see
if that adult is with its chick because
when it is it'll snuggle in close to it
and then you can see when it's about to
feed it so i'm able to say to people
look you see that one over there that's
its chick it's not a stranger if you
like and then it will stand there and
regurgitate its meal of you know fish
squid krill
to the chick which is a lot more
photogenic than i'm making it sound but
you know being able to do that kind of
thing and and help people see little
bits of
behavior is a cool thing to do same when
i'm taking people on safari you know if
you see a leopard and you can anticipate
what that leopard's going to do because
i take people in safari to zambia every
year and
watching marine mammals in
alaska whatever it is it's just
trying to get the detail and and trying
to help them tell a story with their
photos so if you have one supposed very
large component which is sort of your
venn diagram of strengths of helping
people anticipate or perhaps first just
see
the behaviors right yeah so
certainly you have your books are there
any other books that you've gifted most
to other people i actually gifted one
recently a friend of mine ian dawson he
trains mountain rescue people mountain
rescuers in scotland and he was working
with me at the north pole and he'd never
seen a polar bear before he absolutely
fell in love with the environment and i
gifted him a book called arctic dreams
by barry lopez
this is on my to read lists of wolves
and men by barry lopez is one of my
favorite non-fiction books i've read in
the last 10 years
and arctic dreams i was just saying on
the way here
in the airplane that i wished i had
arctic trees so i haven't read it yet it
is a magical book and yeah i gifted that
to ian and i know he loved it and um
that is a great read you have to
immediately dash off well perhaps not
now but when you get back to
civilization yeah that's a that's a
really beautiful book and i've brought
that for quite a few people and there's
also a fabulous book on polar bears
called imaginatively enough polar bears
uh something like their ecology
behavior something like that by ian
sterling and ian is the world's leading
polar bear biologist who is a fantastic
person
and
i've had some amazing experiences with
him going tagging polar bears and
just yeah so that's another brilliant
book and having worked a lot with the
inuit in the canadian high arctic i've
got quite a large collection of
books about arctic stuff whether it's
wildlife or the unit themselves or
polar art and so on so we'll link to all
these for folks in the show notes
afterwards so we'll give that url a
little bit later but
i'm curious about polar bears i've never
seen a polar bear and i was chatting
with some folks here we have a lot of
staff from alaska we have folks from
baffin island
and
a number of them have commented because
i was asking about grizzly bears as well
about how small grizzly bears seem
compared to polar bears which is
kind of uh mind-boggling for me to even
ponder because i've seen grizzly bears
and they're by no means they don't
strike me as small
and
i'm wondering why polar bears are so
huge because you'd think
their task of hunting seems to be much
more difficult than say grizzly bear i'd
say so yeah so wouldn't it make more
sense that to sustain
a larger body requiring more calories
would be better suited to the
environment of the grizzly bear as
opposed to
the arctic so why are polar bears so
huge what am i missing well for starters
they have to be able to
survive a few months without food when
the sea ice breaks up because they need
sea ice as a hunting platform to hunt
for
amongst other things ring seals which is
the most numerous seal in the world
that's their favorite prey but they can
also help hunt other seals
sorry rustling a bit there because i'm
sitting here in my parka
my head's getting pretty chilly
i need a little fur around the face yeah
also you've maybe seen footage of in
documentaries where they could they'll
pound the ice and break through the eyes
to break into a seal there so they can
break through several inches of snow and
ice so they've got to be pretty hefty to
do that that's right yeah and they'll so
the seals the ring seals will build a
little snow layer under the ice and
they'll be in there with their pup and
then the polar bears will walk along and
they'll be able to sniff the seal
through the ice and then pound on that
but i mean the seal layer it's
effectively a burrow
so it's like a little layer under the
snow so they will come up
from the ocean and there'll be a hole
kind of into this little
den this little pocket and then there's
a i think the word is ugly this little
tiny little hole which is open to the
air where they can breathe and you know
both the inuit and bears can
spot this quite how i'm not sure still
and then the other thing is that they
will as well as being you know pounding
through the ice and as i mentioned you
know there'll be a pregnant female when
she goes into the the maternity zen when
the ice breaks up she's going to be in
that for a few months so they give birth
to the
cub
and it'll be about the size of a guinea
pig and she'll be in the maternity den
with that cub for about three months
before they emerge out in about march
april time so she's got to have
the
subcutaneous fat for her to last that
time and actually what there's a really
cool fact i i i managed to get this into
this form i made about polar bears with
ian sterling and and david attenborough
so in 1990
oh gosh
i think it was 93 it might be 98 mount
pinatubo erupted in the philippines
and when that you think what the heck's
that got to do with polar bears right so
when mount pinatubo erupted in the
philippines it threw up huge amounts of
volcanic ash into the atmosphere
and
that obviously stopped some of the solar
radiation getting through so the
following spring temperatures were about
one and a half degrees cooler than
normal and
that meant
that the sea ice stayed longer than it
would usually maybe an extra couple of
weeks
and so that meant the polar bears
including the free mills they were able
to feed up a lot more on ring seals put
on more weight so that when they went
into those maternity dens they were able
to
basically have
more cubs
or hang on to their cubs and the cubs
were in healthier condition so they
actually called the bears that emerged
at spring the pinatubo bears isn't that
incredible
so this
volcano in the philippines was directly
linked to the success of those bears
isn't that cool
i love that and also actually polar
bears he came up with this great
statistic that polar bear is being
affected by forest fires you think
what's that all about but in the
southern hudson bay population of polar
bears which are the most southerly
population unusually they'll dig
sometimes they'll be digging maternity
dens into river banks where there are
tree roots and so on which will kind of
hold the substrate together but when
there's a forest fire then that will
burn the tree and then that is affecting
how well that den can hold together
anyway all sorts of interesting facts
about polar bears and here we are in the
antarctic yeah wrong pole
yeah i accidentally
antarctica is a real hassle to spell
with your thumbs
on an iphone so i i told a friend of
mine i was going to the arctic to see
penguins and he's like you know you
might want to just double check make
sure you're going in the right direction
i said okay i will well i'll tell you
what you sleep a lot better in a tent on
the sea ice in the antarctic than you do
in the arctic
because
there's a couple of occasions where
we've been woken up in the tents by
polar bears and in fact doug my ex who
we heard about with the divorce whale
doug was filming polar bears with an
inuit friend and they were in the tent
around about march time and it was
pretty chilly so he's kind of huddled in
a sleeping bag and his feet were pressed
against the wall of the tent and he was
woken up by a polar bear pouring his
feet through the wall of the tent
so he woke up andrew our idiot friend
and said hey we've got a bear in camp
and andrew said just open the tent and
it'll run away and he said no you
yeah no thanks i'll let you do that you
seem confident
yeah where'd you think this gray hair
came from
[Music]
does that actually work i mean yeah
yeah they unzip the tent and the bear
ran away
that's so
strange to me because i've also seen
footage of bears like smacking on
windows and trying to get in yeah
absolutely and you know people are
barely regularly killed by them but you
know the first time we ever went to the
arctic
i will never forget it as long as i live
so you know i've got pretty big feet and
i was able to stand and put both of my
feet inside one paw print
and have a bit of space around there
they're so big yeah it's really
incredible and very impressive speaking
of boots i'm in these boots
why are your little toasty feet are well
they're rated down to i guess negative
100 fahrenheit and my toes are cold
that's okay they're not they're not
frost nibbed or frostbitten but your
backside will be soon yeah my ass i
don't know if i can even feel my ass
anymore so where can people find you
online
they can find me on my lovely new
website which is just
soufflood.com floodlight lots of water
um soufflood.com and then you know
twitter and instagram souffload
photography or souffloadphotos
and um yeah love to hear from you we
will link to everything in the show
notes at tim dot blog slash podcast so
please check it out you have to see
sue's work it's
just spectacular it's really and the and
and it's not just the expertise and the
patience and the endurance and the
creative eye that is reflected in the
work
it's also the spectrum of your
photography i mean you it's not just
even if it were solely in say antarctica
it would still be amazing but you
operate and have been able to capture
such incredible visuals in so many
different environments with so many
different animals
it's very impressive i must say thanks
so much but you know my mum tim she
always used to say how come you're so
patient with animals and not with people
what's your answer there
they don't talk back yeah something
something like that and um yeah it's a
lot easier to be uh patient with a
i know a polar bear or a leopard than
some some people but yeah it's uh thank
you for that lovely comment and you know
it's a massive privilege to do what i do
for a job and i never forget it and you
know the great thing is going back to
full circle to when i was at school
because um when i was about 15
i was asked by a teacher at school
what do you want to do when you leave
school and i said i want to make
wildlife films with david attenborough
and was told
nobody gets to do that
um how about cooking
which was obviously a non-sequitur and
a few years ago i was invited back to my
school to
hand out prizes on prize giving day and
give a speech in chester cathedral so i
was able to tell that story and say you
know if you have a dream to pursue
something
pursue it because you know i was never
the smartest i was never the hardest
working but i knew what i wanted to do
and i'm too stubborn to give up so
that's probably the
secret of some of the success but it's a
privilege to
a get to do it and b talk to you about
it so thank you it's great i mean what
what a
spectacular environment i can't think of
the next time that i'll have a chance to
sit in a
snow slash ice lounge
in this sort of half spherical tent it's
like being inside the top half of a
20-sided die for any
dnd nerds out there
this ice table
that has been created
pretty fancy and i am very impressed
that the gear has actually
lasted this long
and i also want to give credit where
credit is due we have hannah to thank
for many things yeah keeping us alive
and running this camp
being
very high on the list but also
just to humanize you a little bit she
was telling a story as we were kind of
huddled around the oven in there
that i guess it was a previous trip
where there was a daily practice of
sitting down and she would say
maybe you can fill in the gaps here sue
you have to tell us three good things
about yourself
because you're so bad at it
she did say that and she brought it up
the other day yeah that is not my high
suit um i
have constant imposter syndrome constant
and so hannah punished me by trying to
get me to say three nice things about
myself but it's funny you make me think
to him there was this event
i'm still astonished that i was invited
to this event at buckingham palace to go
and meet the queen as a result of my
photography and my first reaction when i
got this was this was someone playing a
joke on me
yeah and it wasn't i might just
find that remarkable and i've got one of
my photos hanging on the wall of
buckingham palace which wow wow i mean
the queen good grief and i did the
world's worst curtsy which was having
watched american football on tv it would
not have looked out of place an american
football match or a rugby scrub in wales
but but anyway it was a rare chance for
me to wear a dress that doesn't happen
very often that and when i got married i
think was the last time
amazing well
two a great many adventures had and a
great many adventures to come yeah
really wonderful to spend time with you
you've been so generous with everyone
here
and it's really
wonderful to see
how excited you still are
to engage with the work being out there
and sitting out there and listening to
the penguins and watching the penguins
as i have been has always gone hand in
hand with watching you on your side
crawling around crawling around
crawling around in penguin
doing the little come on come on
the little hand beckoning together yeah
and i often talk to you know i'll often
talk to wildlife because you you know
whether it's a
you'll often
catch something's attention if you start
talking to it or you know if you're in
the water with a humpback whale or
something you can
start singing down your snorkel or you
know think something where you're going
to
catch something substantial pitch their
attention so now next thing we have to
do is we have to go to the arctic
together then we can do a podcast about
more polar bear stories
i'm very very into it as long as i don't
have to be the one unzipping the tent
i'm all for it yeah and there won't be a
tent there'll be a luxury icebreaker i'm
all over it don't worry
i'll bring up
i'll bring my podcast studio with me
which for those who obviously can't see
this is just
an h6 zoom sitting on my thigh it's the
only warmth which i'm currently getting
and let's not forget your special hat oh
yes yes and then i have i have a banya a
russian banya hat a
sauna
which insulates your head especially if
you're bald like i am so you don't turn
your ears into uh you know chinese
dumplings when you're in these things
and it turns out to be perfect for an
ice table when you want to put your gear
down without destroying it no expense
bad no expense spared
for my
my like hand-me-down russian bonya hat
and i would say this has been been a
great success so thank you again sue hey
thank you absolutely loved it and uh
really appreciate the opportunity and
yeah look forward to the arctic next
north pole here we come north pole here
we come and everybody check it out
siouxflood.com
and we'll link to all the socials you're
on all the uh on the various networks
and so on where are you most active on
social media
probably instagram instagram what is
your instagram handle soufflord
photography or is it soufflood photos
i'm just blanking
we'll put the right one in pretty pretty
easy to find two flood ph and then yeah
it will pop right up yeah so check it
out everybody i can't recommend it
highly enough
and
sue what a gift your work and your
teaching is
so thank you again for that i'm cringing
him out and he's saying something nice i
know it's nice thanks nice thanks
nice things and uh well deserved and to
everybody listening i'm gonna go warm up
my body and my feet and my
rear side
with some hot coffee hot instant coffee
i love
i would say it's shitty but i really
enjoy
hot
instant coffee
yeah you just think about it
[Laughter]
where's my cappuccino
when i need to yeah well you know i'm
from long island no one ever accused me
of being too high class
so i'm showing my true colors and
everybody listening thank you so much
for listening until next time
be safe be adventurous let someone else
unzip the tent
and you'll be able to find everything at
tim.log podcast for links to everything
we've discussed
and
just one more thing boys and girls this
is an afterward i forgot to mention
something and that is in february of
2021 sue won the climate change category
in the science photographer of the year
contest which was run by the royal
photographic society and this image is
pretty
stunning it's beautiful
also shocking in some ways and you just
have to google north pole underwater
sioux flood and the image will pop right
up and i recommend checking it out
thanks for listening
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log slash friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and i'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for sleep enhancing sleep and
eight sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are add the pod pro cover to
your current mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit it also
splits your bed in half so your partner
can choose a totally different
temperature my girlfriend runs hot all
the time she doesn't need cooling she
loves the heat and we can have our own
bespoke temperatures on either side
which is exactly what we're doing now
for me and for many people the result
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40 and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for enhanced recovery so
you can take on the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250 off of
the pod pro cover that's a lot simply go
to eight sleep dot com slash tim or use
code tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use coupon
code tim tim eight sleep dot com slash
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've asked this for years
the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy you're not sure if your meals
where they should be it covers your
bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was got
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multimineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient-dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure that you are getting what
you need ag-1 makes it easy to get a lot
of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available it's also nsf
certified for sport making it safe for
competitive athletes as what's on the
label is in the powder it's the ultimate
all-in-one nutritional supplement bundle
in one easy scoop right now athletic
greens is giving my audience a special
offer on top of their all-in-one formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tip
[Applause]